what was it like like going fully into
the road it didn't feel it but you
didn't House of the Dragon has some
incredible costumes makeup and
Prosthetics created by a talented
dedicated team but most of the time the
actors found themselves struggling to
get through hours in the makeup chair
putting on uncomfortable dresses or
complete fight scenes wearing painful
stiff plastic armor we've got a lot to
talk about here some angles like I'm
good from the side I'm quite it's quite
a lot from the front number one it was a
painful day for the entire cast we are
talking of course about the birth scene
in episode one games a massively long
day and it was a very emotional Scene It
was more emotional than what's finally
caught the costume designers had to
create 14 identical white dresses so
they could start fresh from every take
beneath the dress though were some very
uncomfortable tubes it sounds like
nothing but you've got all these tubes
pumping the blood it becomes very very
technical having to change the dresses
and reapply the tubes for each take was
definitely a brutal process regardless
of the scene's heavy content the cast
found that day not only physically
exhausting but massively emotional and
harrowing at times they operated on a
closed set that day so nobody who wasn't
part of the scene was allowed to be
present number two you'd be surprised
how early they have to come in because
of them we're talking 4 AM call times
and the application process definitely
was not an easy one it took several
hours for most of the cast members I had
to come in originally a day before to
have my hair all platters and then
combat the next time
so long Steve Toussaint was the only
cast member who didn't mind because well
with a wig when you start off with this
as your base it's so easy with him is
the exception the cast unanimously hated
the wig process Patty was another one
which is like forever
number three another majorly early call
time you've heard of the troubles in the
stepsters
nearest princes feeding West Rossi's
Sailors to the crabs his left arm is
covered in grayscale the the same
disease that affected Shireen Baratheon
and Jorah Mormont in Game of Thrones the
hair makeup and Prosthetics team added
more details around the grayscale to
give the skin a more raw look before
layering the psoriasis on top of it
Daniel Scott Smith had to arrive seven
hours before the cameras started rolling
so the crew could apply all of the
costuming makeup and even a partial Wig
by the end of the season they got the
application process down to about five
hours
number four beautiful yes but super
uncomfortable because the dresses were
so elaborate and heavy they couldn't
really sit properly or even relax
between takes
especially like this because the dresses
were uncomfortable and I've got a bad
back they had to be particularly mindful
when it came to taking every step
because of how much it restricted their
movement the dresses were also designed
to carry some really important symbolism
the costume team put a lot of thought
into it in the beginning renera is in
light colors she's in light yellow she's
in beige she's just a young girl she's
not yet dragged into the family you will
see little by little she's going to
start wearing the color of the family
and the same with Allison did you find
any other hidden meanings or symbols in
these characters outfits let us know in
the comments it was also a question of
doing better it was just a question of
doing something beautiful number five
also known as a walking torture chamber
though Steve to Saint had no problem
with his wig he really struggled with
the armor he had to wear especially
during fight scenes
[Music]
apparently both gray and McTavish and
Fabian Frankel would complain to him
about their armor throughout their
rehearsals and scenes oh it's digging in
here ah I'm in pain we just go oh shut
up deal with it and when I finally had
mine on I was like oh God I understand
what you mean oh it hurts
number six because the armor itself
wasn't painful enough the armor wasn't
actually real it was pretty light
plastic so to enhance the heaviness of
it they had to wear a tunic underneath
which was the real villain when it came
to how restricted they were I just
remembered I'm wearing this very heavy
tunic I suppose very heavy and very
thick your movements are suddenly
incredibly restricted it became
something of a torture chamber actually
a walking torture chamber but hopefully
it'll look good anyway number seven one
of the most hindering costume pieces
when Matt Smith was doing some stunt
work in Portugal he suffered a pretty
serious injury to the disc in his neck
which he blames the helmet for that was
doing a stunt in a helmet hit the disc
in my neck in Portugal it's a [ __ ]
pain in the neck literally
metaphorically and physically it seems
like those helmets were designed more
for Style than safety
number eight
super heavy and potentially dangerous
during scenes Fabian Frankel had a
rather unfortunate mishap his first day
using a sword our first rehearsal with
Matt I smashed him in the face with a
sword we are sure those swords were
accidentally smashed into a ton of
things constantly being strapped to most
of the actors
pretty quickly luckily with a bit of
practice he was able to get a bit better
at it and not get fired number nine to
transform into King viserys Patty
Constantine goes through a lot in the
makeup chair luckily for all the crew
he's an extremely patient guy I think my
makeup team would probably tell you
another story well maybe less patient at
times but the whole process takes
several hours you've been in makeup for
like six hours not scratch on him Matt
Smith who was known as the guy on set
who hated wigs more than anyone can't
relate he had more to say about his work
and he hated them and he had more of
them number 10 a painful audition turned
into a successful casting Emma Darcy had
to do tons of self tapes for their
audition process and at one point had to
improvise homemade hair somewhere in the
midst of that I got on a zoom call with
showrunner's Miguel and Ryan and Miguel
asked me if I had a wig Darcy who
usually Sports a short haircut responded
with do I look like a person who owns a
wig all they had were some hair
extensions left over from a job to
achieve these makeshift extensions they
ended up hot gluing them to some wig
grips and then every time we taped after
that I would sit in front of the Telly
and my partner would do my hair
extensions for an hour and a half before
we taped anything I love wearing a wig
it turns out which yeah I do it's just
it's just so transformative number 11.
this is more dreadful for the hair and
makeup team we talked about how the wigs
take hours to apply and get right Olivia
Cook gives us some insight into the
team's daily Horrors and then you've got
all the battle scenes where the wigs get
destroyed from all the blood and the
gunk that's been being thrown around you
know you can just see the despair from
the hair and makeup team that's going to
be another six hours in the chair
it's the biggest TV chef so yeah so this
is a bit of pressure
number 12 the most important but most
uncomfortable seat in the show Patty
considine considers the throne part of
his costume as he's the only one that
should be using it when I saw stills of
him sitting on I'm like I'm like no
one's allowed to sit on that like we
said though not really a fun time to
actually sit on it's not a comfortable
seat yeah it's not as comfy as it looks
after seeing the hours of prep the
actors go through in the makeup chair
the painful armor they have to wear the
dangerous swords they have to carry and
the dreaded wigs that take hours to
apply we definitely have a lot more
respect for the house of the Dragon
actors what was your favorite costume
piece
foreign